they're back certain white middle-class
racial justice activists with too much
time on their hands have decided to
exploit Halloween to push their
ideological dogma
apparently dressing your white children
up as non-white characters is cultural
appropriation and somehow racist one
activist said she talked her daughter
out of dressing up as the Polynesian
Moana because she wasn't from the
Pacific Islands or even Elsa from frozen
because she also wasn't blonde poor
daughter but how far do you take it if
dressing like Moana isn't allowed what
about those who wrote the story or even
animated it the kind of world this
creates is the opposite of anti-racist
if these people had their way we'd all
be segregated cultures in silos and we
people of color would be deemed
authentic only if we aped the crudest of
stereotypes about our culture's
Jamaicans with dreadlocks Muslim women
covering their faces cultural
appropriation as a concept is racism
dressed up as anti racism I say white
children looking up to role models from
people of color is a good thing they're
not doing it as a mockery this is not
blackface we should all participate in
and celebrate different cultures rather
than designate and isolate them Majid I
actually agree with you I so buy focus
on for example a Halloween costume
element of your conversation I love
Halloween I will you know be the first
in there to get into fancy dress I think
it's wonderful and you know I don't I
had somebody I went to a Halloween party
and there was a person that was dressed
up and they were very heavily made to
look like they were burn and somebody
was saying you know I find that deeply
offensive because what if you are you
know a burns victim and and so you
depending on which avenue you go down
there's always a reason why someone can
feel offended by something and sometimes
they valid and sometimes they're not I'm
off the minds that that I actually think
about what is the intent behind people
doing whatever it is that they're doing
and more of and they're not people don't
have bad intentions people don't want to
upset people so I think that we've just
got to be careful that we're not getting
too overly sensitive and too easily
offended where the offense and the
racism and things that people describe
it's just
not meant sorry yeah you end up in the
kind of world where that offense is then
policed I mean in King's College now
they have what they're calling safe
space marshals who are patrolling
speeches they did it with Jacob Reese's
mock speech five paid for marshals paid
for by King's College just there to make
sure that nobody was offended by what he
said and it's like look I have been a
political prisoner in Egypt I witnessed
torture Halloween is a time where I see
things that I'm you know that remind me
of things I saw in prison I'm not going
to turn up and say to people in a
Halloween party you can't dress like
that because it reminds me of certain
things I see this is what I I think what
is dangerous is there's political
correctness and then there's political
correctness when it goes too far and I
think what's happened in the whole world
now is we've gone and tipped over and
when it goes too far actually is exactly
the opposite of what is trying to
achieve it becomes almost autocratic and
here's an example that a school in
Canada published a list of costumes
which kids shouldn't dress up in and
I'll read out the list as they published
it they said you can't wear a dress up
as cowboys and Indians slaves terrorists
gypsies and Rastafarians this is and
there many other examples in Canada
people should dress up as those things
no I'm saying that for a school to
actually prescribe that you can't dress
up as this this and this because when I
read that list I thought and I have some
sympathy for what you're saying Regina
and I read the blog that this is all
based on by this month especially Paris
and there things in there I agreed with
and there things I disagreed with I said
I feel sorry for her daughter she got
herself in knots right because it's not
perfect and I I don't think I'm not the
police I don't go around telling
children what they can and can't wear
however where I agree with her is that I
think this is all about context you know
I agree this isn't about segregating
cultures but it is about context so I
was interested that you mentioned this
is not blackface do you think there's
something wrong with that face if it's
done out of mockery yes exactly context
so in the past people have dressed up as
other cultures as a way of making fun of
them and caricaturing them I grew up
seeing people I grew up with very few
black people around me but a fancy dress
parties people would put blackface on an
afro wigs
hold the spliff and it was all a big
joke and you know I that was one of the
only times I saw people referencing my
cultural heritage and I found that
difficult so if it's done in a spirit of
mockery then it's problematic if it's in
a context where people don't actually
know about a culture they have no
curiosity in in it and I think there's
no more honor issue how much do people
know about Polynesian culture other than
the Disney version this is what I think
when Karen said it's gone too far that's
the point because when by saying gone
too far is an implicit acknowledgement
that there are times where this
conversation is valid so for example
cultural theft I recently watched a film
ghost in the shell and then read the
reviews and agreed with lots and lots of
the reviews that they could have cast a
Japanese person in that role instead of
casting Scarlett Johansson because it
was filmed in Japan and there are plenty
of good Japanese actor of actress actors
and there and it's a Japanese story so
when you when cultural theft is a valid
critique from a cultural criticism
perspective or says for example is Sasha
Baron Cohen playing a lychee no I'm
sorry offensive no no this one say first
of all you can't police it anyway it's
the impossible to police it's only ever
going to be a conversation but
especially in the examples I gave where
this young daughter was looking up to
Moana wanted to wanted to aspire to be
like
Moana because the stories of a young
girl finding her own courage to find her
own path there's absolutely nothing
wrong and there was clearly no mockery
involved in that young child wanting to
dress like Moana from the Disney
commentary what I thought was sad was
that you know kid kids are not aware of
color or prejudice or bias they just
they just don't see it and unless this
woman sat her child out and she got into
a heavy discussion about cultural
appropriation about about race about the
proof you see she just what I thought
and and and I and I just think you know
let it all the little kids want to be
princess I mean there was there was one
quote where the little girl said can I
be Elsa from frozen and and else has got
it like a long blonde platitude you can
be Elsa without the plot no you can't
you've got to be L sorry the blah blah I
don't agree that kids don't see color I
think if you are a majority in a
majority you know if you're a white
person in a majority white country you
probably don't see color if you're the
only Polynesian kid in a very white
community and everyone stood suddenly
dresses up as man and you're conscious
that you are the only person from that
culture and that people are starting to
use it now if that's been
done in a respectful way where they're
curious about the culture want to
celebrate it that's one thing if it's to
mock it that's another if you are a
minority you're very aware that you're
the owner to feel that she was
belittling and insulting the polynesian
community she wasn't she just wanted to
go to a party as a princess it could
have been any places they will show you
those two she's gonna show you an image
because we've been talking about where
things go too far I'm curious to see
what you think of this this is a a burka
fancy dress costume and a response from
a woman wearing about who felt that it
was disrespectful so this is this is an
this is a fancy dress costume that many
people who are Muslim or a lot Muslim
find offensive and actually one thing I
won't say in defense of the women who
wrote this blog is that she's a white
American women she's saying that as
white people we also have a duty to
think about the messages we send when we
use other people's cultures and costumes
now one of the problems I have this
debate is often framed as a problem for
minority people I think it's everyone's
responsibility to think aloud the way we
talk I just want to just clarify
something as a Muslim on this in this
debate that's not Muslim culture that's
saudi arabian culture but muslim culture
is as diverse as there are muslims in
the world and so if one takes offense at
saudi arabian culture being mocked then
i'd argue that actually you're mocking
power because in saudi arabia that dress
is enforced by law and women are
punished for not dressing like that so
it deserves mocking you're also doing it
in a context where there is a lot of
prejudice towards nobody but there are
at the relevant last women for not
dressing like that so if we laugh at the
life of brian if we laugh at the Book of
Mormon if we laugh for other power
structures being mocked including white
supremacy we should be able to mock that
tower strata critique that is a taking
how do you know it's a critique of power
I think this outfit
what is that appropriate because that
that's David Walliams
in my opinion is a bit lame actually
he's supposed to be Kim jong-un he has
not done a particularly good job but is
that appropriate is it a good idea to
borrow things from other people's
cultures it isn't isn't that good is not
what were sensors and sometimes to mock
them I think we get distracted by the
clothes all right this isn't about the
clothes it's about the power
as we were saying and the problem is
about it for this little deal with a
burglar lives in a society where
cultures are not equal where some
cultures are still surrounded by
prejudices your mother what would you
say to the girls if you're the mother of
your Sashi photos my daughter who's a
little a beautiful little black girl
with afro hair has a blonde Elsa braid
this is a source of some consternation
because all her friends have heard for
us because she's the only or one of the
only children in her school who has hair
like that and lots the other children do
have blonde braids and she often says I
wish my hair were more like these other
little girls because that's what
princesses look like now I have not to
do what every kid wants different hair
from the one we've got that's not to do
in a society where the predominant
message of what it beautiful and what a
princess look like girl she might have
seen the hair was like - massive in
those days I mean I could work both ways
and actually it's just about who you
look up to really that's all it is who
you aspire to be like in terms of role
models this little girl saw Moana
and aspire to be like her and this
that's innocent there's nothing wrong
with that